mes chers amis je vais donc maintenant
mettre aux voix le projet des
républicain qui vous a été
transmis déjà la synthèse des Convention
il y a une quinzaine de jours vous avez
reçu par mail hier la
synthèse et vous avez récupéré ce matin
le document de plus de 350 pages qui est
ici alors vous avez toujours vos petits
cartons je vais donc mettre au voix le
projet des républicains pour
2017 qui est
pour qui est
contre non s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît je vous rappelle nous sommes une
famille politique moderne nous débattons
nous discutons projet contre projet et
la parole est à vous c'est vous qui
votez à la
fin alors je note les contes 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9
10 11 12
13 14 au fond labas 14 contre qui
s'abstient ceux qui
s'abstientent ceux qui s'abstient lève
la
main merci mes chers amis le projet des
républicains est donc
adopté